kehrtwende bei der korona app die
regierung will die daten jetzt doch
nicht mehr zentral speichern
endlich wieder raus nach sechs wochen
ausgangssperre dürfen in spanien seit
heute wieder kinder auf die straße und
folgenschwere angst vor corona immer
öfter kommen ernsthaft kranke aus furcht
vor einer infektion nicht in die
notaufnahme
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg guten abend und
willkommen schön dass sie dabei sind
die app ist eine der großen hoffnungen
im kampf gegen korona sie soll warnen
wenn man kontakt zu einem infizierten
hatte in anderen ländern sind solche
apps schon im einsatz
hierzulande wird noch diskutiert vor
allem über die frage wo landen die daten
all der nutzer die freiwillig mitmachen
die regierung war bis jetzt für einen
zentralen server dagegen aber sperrten
sich apple und google und auch
datenschützer jetzt bei der dezentralen
variante bleiben die daten auf den
handys und sollen dort anonym
ausgewertet werden weniger berichtet die
daten der app nutzer auf einem zentralen
server speichern
das wollte vor allem jens spahn doch die
kritik an der idee des
gesundheitsministers war groß von
datenschützern wissenschaft und
wirtschaft
die kehrtwende der bundesregierung kommt
heute leise und etwas verklausuliert per
pressemitteilung die nutzung der app
durch möglichst große teile der
bevölkerung ist die grundlage ihres
erfolges um dieses ziel zu erreichen
setzt die bundesregierung auf eine
dezentrale software-architektur
dezentral statt zentral das überrascht
selbst die kritiker dieser schritt
signalisiert die bundesregierung setzt
auf datensparsamkeit sie will keine
massenüberwachung im schilde führen und
signalisiert somit mit dieser
architektur
kannst du uns vertrauen weil du mit
dieser architektur uns nicht vertrauen
muss und nicht vertrauen zu müssen ist
ja die vertrauensbildende maßnahme
noch ist vieles nicht klar zum beispiel
mit welcher technik die app ausgestattet
sein soll um von telefon zu telefon
feststellen zu können wer wo kontakt zu
einem infizierten hatte die fragen sind
komplex die zeit läuft wir haben
wertvolle zeit verloren dadurch dass die
debatte einen anderen weg genommen hat
wir hatten von vornherein sagen müssen
das dezentral selbstverständlich
freiwillig und es hätte auch mehr
transparenz seitens der ministerien
gehalten freiwilligkeit darin besteht
einig
es müssten mindestens 60 prozent der
bürger mitmachen damit die app hilft die
pandemie zu bekämpfen
gleich nach uns in berlin direkt
gesundheitsminister sparen im gespräch
auch zur corona app und wie entwickelt
sich die zahl der angesteckten hier der
stand vor einer halben stunde danach
sind laut johns hopkins universität in
deutschland mehr als 157.000 corona
infizierte durch tests bestätigt das
sind gut 1600 mehr als gestern um diese
zeit davon gelten fast 110.000
betroffener als genesen 5880 menschen
sind bislang in verbindung mit dem virus
gestorben ein recht auf home office das
plant arbeitsminister heil auch für die
zeit nach corona ein entsprechendes
gesetz will er bis zum herbst vorlegen
sagte er der bild am sonntag wenn der
arbeitsplatz es zulässt dann soll jeder
zu hause arbeiten dürfen so heil
nach seinen angaben tun dass aktuell
geschätzt acht millionen menschen in
deutschland etwa ein viertel der
beschäftigten
die arbeitgeberverbände lehnen den
vorstoß ab wenn kinder wegen corona
wochenlang nicht raus dürfen dann geht
das allen beteiligten an die nerven in
spanien mit weltweit der zweithöchsten
zahl von infizierten durfte der
nachwuchs heute erstmals wieder vor die
tür
christel hass berichtet endlich wieder
raus platz haben sich bewegen was in
normalen zeiten völlig
selbstverständlich ist wird in spanien
heute gefeiert
kinder bis 14 dürfen wieder vor die tür
nach sechs wochen nicht raus zu können
ist eine große veränderung und das ist
ziemlich schwer auszuhalten
ich fühle mich einfach gut es ist ein
gefühl der freiheit endlich frei sein
rennen können das ist unglaublich
es ist noch nicht die ganz große
freiheit nur eine stunde nur in
begleitung und nur in einem umkreis von
einem kilometer
aber eine große erleichterung auch für
die eltern die kinder müssen ja
beschäftigt werden und wie eltern haben
unsere jobs und viel zu tun da ist es
nicht immer leicht sich um sie zu
kümmern
spanien hat eine der strengsten
ausgangssperren europas nur zum
einkaufen oder für arztbesuche dürfen
erwachsene vor die tür
kinder mussten bis jetzt ganz zu hause
bleiben die kinder leiden unter solchen
beschränkungen sie leiden darunter in
form von unsicherheit ungewissheit angst
und furcht
jetzt also ein kleines bisschen
normalität und premier sanchez
verspricht nun auch lockerungen für die
erwachsenen aber billbrook dem 2 mai
darf man alleine draußen sport machen
und mit personen aus dem gleichen
haushalt spazierengehen publikum wie
mich das alles natürlich nur wenn sich
der positive trend bei corona bestätigt
erstmals gibt es in spanien mehr
genesene als neuinfektionen hierzulande
zeigt sich mittlerweile in vielen
kliniken dass in den notaufnahmen
weniger los ist offenbar für die
aktuelle corona situation dazu dass
manche patienten bedenken haben sich ans
krankenhaus zu wenden
trotz akuter probleme heike kruse
berichtet neurochirurg müssen kümmert
sich oft um 4 schlaganfall patienten
täglich
momentan gibt es tage ohne einen
einzigen notfall die korona krise hat
auch die notaufnahmen leergefegt
überfüllung und lange wartezeiten in den
krankenhäusern praktisch über nacht
wurde alles anders
er gab es praktisch eine schockstarre wo
wir
hier im krankenhaus gesessen haben und
gesagt haben wo sind denn die patienten
mit den schlaganfällen wo sind die
patienten mit den herzinfarkten oder
anderen schwerwiegenden erkrankungen die
angst sich in der klinik mit dem virus
zu infizieren hat für einige menschen
inzwischen schlimme folgen wenn sie dann
doch in die notaufnahme kommen ist es
manchmal schon zu spät
er hat sie ihn zunehmend patienten die
wir eigentlich in deutschland so selten
gesehen haben dass mit fortgeschrittenen
symptomatiken wo in der normalzeit also
vor corona die patienten längst in einem
krankenhaus aufgenommen wären untragbar
gewesen wären es ist eine absurde
situation menschen bräuchten dringend
medizinische hilfe gleichzeitig sind 40
prozent der betten nicht belegt denn für
mögliche kroner patienten waren viele
operationen verschoben worden keine
patienten keine einnahmen aber die
korona pandemie ist noch nicht vorbei
wir wollen einerseits alle vorhaltungen
treffen für eine eventuelle zweite welle
die diskutiert wird und die nicht
unwahrscheinlich ist
andererseits sollen wir jetzt wieder in
so etwas wie eine regelbetrieb übergehen
das geht nicht wir versuchen jetzt einen
spagat zu gehen zwischen diesen beiden
dingen bis heute wurden in heide 16
corona patienten behandelt es sind also
kapazitäten frei sowohl für patienten
als auch für alle anderen auch eine
folge von corona die preise für frische
lebensmittel steigen
gemüse ist um fast ein drittel teurer
geworden ein grund bei uns und in
anderen europäischen ländern fehlen
erntehelfer deutschland importiert den
großteil von obst und gemüse etwa aus
spanien italien und den niederlanden
ganz anderes thema jetzt heute vor 34
jahren der super-gau in tschernobyl im
damals sowjetischen atomkraftwerk etwa
100 kilometer entfernt von kiew
explodiert block 4
tausende menschen sterben viele leiden
an den spätfolgen aktuell brennt es in
der radioaktiv verseuchten sperrzone
gefährliche waldbrände rund um die
atomruine mehr von fugger brennen der
torf qualm die glutnester selbst dort wo
die brände von tschernobyl mittlerweile
gelöscht sind ist die
noch nicht vorüber mit dem rauch steigen
radioaktive partikel auf die 34 jahre
lang in boden und bäumen gelagert waren
seit anfang april brennt es um den
explodierten atomreaktor der ukrainische
katastrophenschutz habe viel zu
zögerlich auf den ausbruch der feuer
reagiert bemängeln fachleute dies hätte
man von anfang an mehr ressourcen
eingesetzt wäre der brand nach drei
tagen vergessen gewesen
es wäre ein kleiner waldbrand geblieben
jetzt ist es der größte in der
geschichte der sperrzone von tschernobyl
willst du die kritik an der politischen
führung gab es auch 1986 am 26 april
explodierte block 4 des atomkraftwerks
von tschernobyl die sowjetunion
versuchte den unfall zu vertuschen
das ausmaß der strahlung geheim zu
halten tausende menschen starben
zehntausende litten unter den spätfolgen
der katastrophe seit es brennt meldet
nicht nur die ukraine sondern auch
norwegen leicht erhöhte cäsium 137 werte
gesundheitsgefährdend sei die gemessene
radioaktivität aber nicht beteuern die
behörden den menschen in der region
bleibt nur das zu glauben
einen detaillierten blick auf den
unglücksreaktor ermöglicht ihnen die
zdf- heute- app jede phase der
ereignisse können sie da mit einem
interaktiven 3d modell genau unter die
lupe nehmen und zum schluss noch ein
spektakuläres bild in der schweiz flach
ins gras gesprüht aber so dass das auge
von oben gesehen viel mehr draus macht
zeit nimmt sich der künstler
er habe eine positive botschaft kreieren
wollen mögen doch bitte die menschen
nach der korona krise gemeinsam in die
gleiche richtung bieten zunächst noch
der blick aufs wetter morgen gibt es
viel sonne im tagesverlauf auch einige
wolken
südlich der donau vereinzelt schauer
höchsttemperatur 19 bis 25
an der see 15 grad das war es von uns um
viertel vor zehn begrüßt sie im
heute-journal claus kleber morgen um 19
uhr hier petra gerster wir danken für
interesse wünschen ihnen noch einen
schönen abend und empfehlen jetzt
wärmstens berlin direkt mit theo koll